In this tutorial, we'll be
walking through the steps it
takes to set up IntelliJ
IDEA to run to YouTube
API samples for Java.
This video was recorded using
IntelliJ IDEA 12 Community
Edition, but the process for
other versions should be very
similar, even if the menus may
not look exactly the same.
When you first open IntelliJ
IDEA, you're presented with
several options to
open a project
or start a new project.
Select Import Project.
Browse to the folder containing
the YouTube API
samples you want to import.
If you don't have these samples
yet, you'll need to
download these from
code.google.com/
p/youtube-api-samples.
There's another video showing
you how to do this, as well as
how to register your API keys.
For now, I'm going to go ahead
and import the topic sample.
You only need to select
a folder, click OK.
Select Import Project
from External
Model and click Maven.
Click Next.
Click Next again, if
there are no other
settings you want to change.
You should now be presented with
the name of the project,
which corresponds to the sample
you want to import.
I want to import the topic
sample, so this
looks correct to me.
I'm going to click Next.
Select your JDK.
If a JDK doesn't appear, you'll
need to add one using
the Plus button.
I'm not going to go too much
into detail about how to do
this, because this could
be different on
every single system.
But if you're using a recent
version of Linux, for
instance, this should be
under /user/lib/jvm.
If you're not sure where this
is, it's probably best to go
to your favorite search engine
and search for JDK location
operating system version.
Replace operating system and
version, which are operating
system and version.
Click Next.
Again, change any settings
that you want to change.
Click Next, and click Finish.
What you'll see is that Maven is
now downloading the sample
dependencies in the
background.
When this is completed, you'll
be able to open up the sample
code and compile it.
I'm going to go ahead
and click Run.